we're going to begin with very serious
news and it's in the middle east with
the worst fighting between
israel and palestinians in nearly seven
[Music]
years
listen and look at those pictures you
are looking at israeli missiles
exploding in gaza overnight just one of
the many attacks
since this latest confrontation flared
up palestinian militants have fired
hundreds of rockets at israel
about 50 people have been killed on both
sides including
some children elizabeth palmer is
following all of this elizabeth
what led to the violence to begin with
good morning to you
good morning well this round of violence
actually started
weeks ago with an israeli court order to
evict
some palestinian families from their
homes in east jerusalem
but it really caught fire over the
weekend just gone by when israeli police
clashed with palestinian protesters
around the very holy al-aqsa mosque
now of course it's morphed into open war
overnight israeli airstrikes pounded
gaza
again the target says the israeli
military are hamas and islamic jihad
leaders and their installations
the material damage is immense and for
humans in this
overcrowded enclave
there is no safe place
nine-year-old yazan zahara happened to
be in the street when a missile exploded
with shrapnel
the palestinian health authority says 48
people have died this week
including 14 children and hundreds are
wounded
and traumatized
the counter-attack on israel by hamas
and islamic jihad
has been relentless too yesterday
evening a rocket barrage
lit up the skies over tel aviv while on
the ground
sirens wailed and people ran for cover
israel's military says more than a
thousand rockets have been fired from
gaza
six israelis including a child have been
killed since
monday the casualties and the damage
would have been greater
but for israeli interceptor rockets the
so-called
iron dome which blew most of the
incoming missiles to pieces
but this is not just an air war there's
been violence on the ground
too last night in ramallah on the west
bank
israel's military fired tear gas to
chase away hundreds of young men who
like most palestinians have had enough
of the israeli occupation
and there is no end in sight israeli's
defense minister this morning said that
more attacks were coming on
armed palestinian groups to bring what
he called
total long-term quiet tony yeah no end
in sight liz palmer in london or we
should recall that this is going on
in gaza which is the size of
philadelphia in a country that's barely
bigger than vermont
and the end result is that each night
families and children
are going to bed afraid terrified tony
that made me think about you
on my own your own children including my
own some people may know i have two
older kids who live with their mother in
tel aviv they spent the night in an air
raid uh
in a shelter uh my daughter was in tears
uh and i'm also acutely aware of the
fact that over in gaza their
children going to bed in a pile of
rubble not getting up
yeah and so you have a situation where
for decades now
leaders on both sides seem to be finding
the war instead of finding the peace
and until that dynamic changes our
children
my children are going to be fighting and
dying do you feel they're safe because
how old are your two older children
uh almost 12 and nine yeah so they're
very well aware of what it is they're
very well aware and and
and when i say our children will be
fighting and dying i mean my 12 year old
will be going to the military in six
years
and and and everybody is sucked into the
conflict in that region until there is
a push or a restart to a search for
peace and when you have two people for
one country
there's got to be two countries it's the
only way to do it and i feel for you
doing this job worrying about your kids
new baby on the way
yeah well